okay okay thank you for that uh james
um i'll just say uh welcome to
today's meeting of the governance and
audit committee
and uh to introduce everyone present and
check
that the cameras microphones are working
please confirm your attendance and your
role or job title
when i say your name
councillor kerry boyd president
yeah present chair west gate on sea ward
thank you councillor helen crittenden
yes president eastcliff ramsgate
councillor alan curry uh president
cliftonville west ward thank you
councillor ruth duckworth president
uh cabinet member for estates and
economic development
dane valley ward okay thank you
councillor mike garner our president
yeah some peter's wall counsellor thank
you
councillor george cupp uh president
shadow government member for operational
services and bursting south ward
councillor pat moore present chair
councillor for sir moses montefiore
reward
thank you councillor reese pugh
president chair uh councillor for vanity
villages ward
thank you councillor horace schrub
here chair cliftonville east thank you
and last councillor cedric
towning counselor for clifton released
thank you and also uh
mr tim willis
evening to our tim willis deputy chief
executive and section 151 officer
thank you estelle culligan
evening cher evening councillors um
direct
director of law and democracy thank you
chris blundell evening chair chris
blundell director of finance and deputy
section 151 officer
okay now is there um any officers
that i've missed please that are present
tonight
good evening chairman nick hughes
community services manager and president
obama
thank you
very much i'm sorry christine
[Music]
thank you christine i haven't got you on
my list sorry
thank you very much are there any more
no okay um now if you have any technical
difficulties during the meeting then
please contact the democratic services
officer
on call who would who will attempt to
assist you
today's officer on call is james clapson
and he will put his phone number in the
chat function
for you
may i only also ask participants to mute
your microphone when you are not
speaking as this minimizes background
noise
and will help everyone in the in
listening to the proceedings
and microphones must only be on if the
participant
has been granted permission to speak to
gain permission to speak
please very briefly excuse me
indicate on the chat to the right and
side of the screen
and i will then make a note and go back
to you
once the person speaking has finished
bit of housekeeping would everyone
present please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business and ensure
that you are in a quiet room free from
distraction
for the duration of the meeting
please note that this meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
and following the meeting the recording
will be available on the council's
youtube channel
now before i proceed to
agenda item number one i would like to
record in the minutes
our appreciation and thanks to the
outgoing chairman councillor simon day
for his time hard work and dedication
whilst discharging his duties as
chairman of this committee
during his term of office thank you
um now is there any other member of this
committee
that would like to say a few words on
that
no okay
so what i'll do i'll go straight on now
to
agenda item number one which is electing
a chair
now this this item is to elect a chair
of the governance and audit committee
for the remainder of the municipal
year excuse money i just need to take a
drink
in a minute in a moment i will call for
nominations
if i receive two or more nominations
then i will conduct a vote
if more than two nominations are
received
the person with the least number of
votes will be
eliminated from the process
and the vote will be repeated for the
remaining nominations
this will be repeated until two
nominations remain
and a straight vote can take place
so i will now call for a nomination
so can i have from members of this
committee
can i have a nomination for chairman
uh thank you vice chair um councillor
curry here
i would like to nominate councillor
helen crittenden
and that was that's that's uh councillor
curry yes
that's correct
can i have a second for that nomination
please
i'll second that nomination
and then your countless cash how's it
look worth sorry can't see everybody
sorry councillor dexter can i make a um
nomination please
yes i've got somebody um
i've got rhys pugh next so okay
sorry thanks bertie thank you chair i'd
like to uh
nominate proposed uh councillor kerry
boyd
and i i will second that chair sorry
who's that uh counselor cup i'll second
that
and i think we had a third nomination
who was who's given me the third
nomination there
sorry counselor dexter it was me
councillor braidwoods oh yes okay
can i um nominate um councillor mike
garner please
yes you can i'll second thank you
counting and the second
is cedric
now are there any other nominations
i'll ask again i mean are there any
other nominations
no um okay so we'll proceed with the
vote
and um the first
the first one is councillor helen
critterdon
can i have the votes please for helen
critterton
can i have a show of hands
this is the i've been correct oh nick
you
you've are you going to speak nick
it might be easier chairman to do um
to just call people's names out so if
you go through the list of people that
are in
are in the committee they would just
simply say
crittenden boyd or ghana
the first time around and then whoever
out of those three people has the least
number of votes
drops out and then we go through the
list again saying
canada a or candidate b that would
probably be easier and a bit more
transparent for
the members of the public watching
because i don't think they can everybody
see
the whole screen or everybody at the
same time
yeah but thank you for that thank you
for that advice nicholas i'll
i'll do that then um so
if i make a start
counselor um kerry boyd
who is who is your vote for
if i can vote it'd be for myself if
possible
you can yet thank you okay
[Music]
councillor bertie braidwood
uh for councillor mike garner please
chair
counselor helen crittenden
sorry councillor christendon
and councillor alan curry
councillor christendon
councillor ruth duckworth councillor
christendon
councillor ghana
councillor ghana
councillor george cupp councillor boyd
councillor pat moore councillor
crittenden
councillor reese pugh
councillor boyd chair
councillor horace schrub councillor
ghana
and councillor cedric towning council
ghana
my vote goes to councillor kerry boyd
so if i just add those up then
i make that a three-way tie
so i believe that the
vice chairs vote would
um
i'm not quite sure because we can't take
one off the bottom that's where i'm
struggling next sorry
that's correct so as as the the vice
chairman is acting as the chair he gets
a casting vote
that he would effectively in order to
break the deadlock of having three
people who are all tied would have one
additional vote
that would then allow us to then have uh
two people progressing to the next round
and then we would then repeat the vote
again with a straight vote off between
candidate a or candidate b
right but with my casting vote we'll go
to kerry boyd
so that will now make it five four four
is that correct katie
uh that that is correct i'm just um
so how do we go about that am i right
nick that
that counselor dexter um
votes for for one of the others
and then that will leave a last place if
you like
sorry i'm beyond you sorry um yes i
believe that to be the case
yeah so what happens now then
so counselor dexter if you vote for
either councillor ghana or councillor
christendon
um the other will be eliminated and
we'll have a vote between that person
and councillor boyd i'll vote for
council lagana
so we now have two
contenders one is councillor kerry boyd
and the other is councillor mike garner
that's correct if you go through the
names again and we'll have votes on
i will do nothing
councillor kerry boyd
that'd be councillor coboy as well
please thank you
councillor bertie braybrood uh
councillor mike garner
please jeff
councillor helen crittenden
councillor boyd
councillor alan curry councillor ghana
councillor ruth duckworth council ghana
councillor mike garner
councillor ghana
councillor george cup councillor boyd
please cheer
councillor pat moore
council of ghana please counselor reese
pugh
sorry chair uh councillor boyd
councillor horace shrub councillor ghana
councillor cedric towning
councillor cedric towning
sorry i i i was still muted ghana please
that's okay thank you
i will cast my vote for councillor kerry
boyd
i make that seven votes to
councillor ghana and five to council
avoid
so councillor ghana has been elected
chair of the governance and audit
committee
congratulations mike
thank you thank you very much for for
electing me as chair
um can i uh to can i um thank you on
this vote
and uh ask councillor mike garner
to now take over as chairman just to
discharge the final art item and close
the meeting
okay thank you very much i'm i'm happy
to do that
congratulations thank you thank you very
much i'll just look at the um
the agenda i think if i believe it was
apologies for absence
that's correct no i don't feel it
well i'm sure someone will tell me if
anyone apologized for their
you're not here everyone is an ascendant
so there are no apologies
everybody's here so thank everybody for
attending
and i look forward to seeing you at the
um next meeting on the 3rd of march
where i believe we're going to be um
reviewing and
and signing off the third point